welcome back to the iced coffee hour
my name is alex and i've just been fired
well that's unfortunate
so sorry to hear it alex yeah man
i'm
technically you're it's all right put
yourself together moving on you're
moving on to bigger and better things
but i do think it's worth addressing
that uh if people see a discrepancy and
and kind of what's going on
maybe that maybe they'll notice maybe
not but i think it's i think it's going
to be a a good move for you yeah man i
mean both on board everybody's told me
you know only up from here and i'm gonna
miss working with both of you guys so
for those of you guys that do not know
alex is the assistant that graham and i
hired what was that eight months ago
months ago eight or nine months ago that
was march
yeah this is november oh we know this is
december oh yeah okay yeah so that was
uh that was nine months ago
we hired you welcome you know yeah so uh
yeah alex was the assistant and uh
there's an interesting process by the
way hiring you because we asked that
people just create a youtube video
titled uh what is it graham stephan
interview so we could search for it and
we could see people on camera and uh we
got i don't know 80 submissions it was a
lot it took forever to go through and i
heard i'm not the only one on this
podcast who
has interviewed for that position
because i think you guys had the runner
up here too yeah yeah yeah bulby so you
fire them and then you monetize
it was a mutually beneficial thing
yeah but but anyways alex joined the
team and uh since then he's been working
at what you've been editing clips for
the iced coffee hour you've been editing
the podcast you've been uh instrumental
and instrumental in the design of this
new podcast set yeah and you also do
stuff for this the family you also do
sponsorships for the iced coffee hour
you do a lot of stuff
and
basically we noticed that you were
spread a little bit thin between all of
the stuff you were working on and i'm
sure that was stressing you out and it
was affecting your work and probably you
know your personal life
and we decided it would be a better idea
to change the amount of work that you do
and and redirect your your path with us
with the brand
yeah so that's worth talking about so
you and jack have been working together
very closely these last nine months and
my understanding is that the the
relationship has not always gone
smoothly what so right where are you
that's a joke that's a joke
no you what you were telling me what i
mean what's your experience like working
with jack
honestly honestly
say it no it's been good man i've loved
working with jack guys i
the only complaint i have about working
with jack let's see
uh sometimes he
doesn't uh know when to step in as a as
a
as a as a supervisor superior what do
you mean by that um
you know if some if i have a ton of work
and you've told me this in the past
you're like you know alex uh
if you're too drunk like let me know
and uh i tried to juggle things and so i
probably should have come to you but i i
also think that you should
i hope that you know whoever follows
next to me you're able to step in and
kind of provide more more direction
assistance yeah when somebody is spread
too thin all right other than that
communication sure i could always work
oh you can text back faster yeah but
graham can attest to this jack is the
worst at texting it's really bad i mean
i'll text him something that benefits
him that makes him money i'm not making
any extra money
and i have to follow up with him to hear
back about making you money it's really
bad you know what i've noticed uh jack
puts his phone on do not disturb all the
time when i call him it goes straight to
voicemail yeah it's like hi it's jim
it's jack i can't read the phone right
now but if you leave me a message i will
call you back as soon as i can thank you
bye
because you have the same voicemail as
when you're like 13 years yeah and
you've told me to change that man i love
my voicemail i think it's pretty
everyone hates it except me and my
family loves it too but the problem is
that i'm trying to reach you and it's so
odd but i have two phone numbers and on
one phone number uh do not disturb
applies so just go straight to voicemail
that when that happens i have to call
you on my other number
jack's just bad at texting back okay
there we go and uh yeah so basically
what happened was uh we decided it would
be better for alex to solely work for
graham because prior to that he was
doing a lot of stuff on my end such as
like podcast production and stuff like
that but uh now he's actually stepping
in and editing graham's main channel
videos yeah so i got fired working for
you guys
and got hired
working for graham that is true and that
is the the story there it's been
interesting this has been your first
full week working for me exclusively
yeah and uh what has that been like for
you uh well it's been kind of an odd
week uh just because i i was in the
middle of a move so i wasn't moving um
but if we go ahead and take that out
it's been different just because of the
work schedule right so a lot of the
things that graham has me do is is the
main main channel editing and a lot of
that is like a one day turnaround so
that we can review it the next day and
right now it's also taking me longer uh
just because you know
we're still kind of in training we're
kind of at the final end of it but you
know still you know need to speed up get
used to to what i'm doing there so uh
the biggest thing is the hours so i mean
i work crazy hours and like when people
hear the hours i work they
yes part of me would love to see that
the breakdown of your hours like i would
love to see uh for a week if you could
actually try this track when you start
something and when you end up and we
just we get a week's worth of data and
figure out exactly where the time is
being spent you sound like a skepticist
yeah i want to know you sound like a
skeptic do you think i'm not working i
know you're working but i'm i i'm just i
look back to the time where i was
editing seven videos a week and doing
all of that it was it was 12 uh 10 to 12
hours a day six days a week but i was
doing seven videos a week and that was
planning filming editing for both
channels
and
i could be wrong here did you have a
girlfriend at the time yes damn it but i
think the current breakdown of the hours
working with graham is right now i'm
spending an average of probably 10 hours
a video
um and so we do about three videos a
week so that's 30 hours um so family i'd
say spending anywhere
now between five and eight hours
depending on the almost a family uh so
we're about 38 hours
um and then just
doing
sponsors with jack we spent
an hour sure about an hour um a couple
things filming with you and then just
miscellaneous email yeah stuff like that
that's about right um
and just stuff that comes up
that's that's kind of a that's kind of
what it is about now
what's been the most challenging part of
editing or working with me in general
i think you're so particular in how you
like things and but i think that's a
good thing because i think that's what
you know you have that secret sauce on
your
yes and so when we were we were going
through and training like
gram goes by and if like a cut is one
frame short and for you guys that don't
know how short a frame is
24 frames make up one second of video so
it's 1 24th of a second if a video is
cut 124th of a second too long or too
short
graham notices
and
uh
it's kind of
weird
uh that it's so
particular but it's also
other than that i mean he's particular
in the cuts and what he uses and stuff
like that so uh but i think the more
that we've worked together the closer i
get to you because
um we're thinking about the same type of
humor and stuff like that and and i
think that
at first we were editing videos you
would edit yours yep i would edit mine
and at first i hate even i hated my
videos i mean they were bad um but then
as we as we got going we would do the
same type of uh
we would put the same type of humor yeah
and that was the best training so for
those that don't know i had alex edit
all of my videos i think for like two to
three weeks i would edit mine
and i i would have alex edit his own
version and then we'd sit there the next
day and compare our videos side by side
until they got close enough
where
we're making the same jokes in the same
spots because we just uh you know it
just takes some time but i would say
this three weeks were so helpful in
doing that yeah and to be fair i mean
you were taking kind of a leap right
because you were
you're paying me um less than what you
paid me now for the for the videos but
if it didn't work out i mean
you know i'm surprised grandma graham
shelled out some some cash there yeah
let's say well the thing is if it wasn't
going to work out we would know pretty
quickly we would know within about two
to three weeks if it wasn't going to
work out and so the investment was
actually not that bad to test it and if
it did work out the upside's really
great and if it didn't work out then you
know it's a write-off yeah and i just
want to be clear for people listening to
uh they didn't they didn't gram and jack
didn't force me to go down this this
road i think graham just wanted to hire
an editor
he doesn't like new people and uh
although jack jack
you're gonna say it aren't you go ahead
go yeah i got the short end of the stick
here okay so basically what happened was
graham wanted someone to hide
to do his main channel videos okay which
is totally understandable he shouldn't
be doing those now he shouldn't have
been doing them a year ago so he wanted
to hire an editor he said you know what
let's hire in-house let's hire alex
because jack you probably don't want to
do it i said yeah that's uh that does
not sound like a good idea because alex
has shared work responsibility between
graham and i we both pay half of his
salary each okay
we used to yeah ending december 1st and
now graham on the side wants to provide
more work for alex outside side hustle i
know but the issue is i said graham
there's no way that alex is going to be
able to spend more time doing you know
editing your main channel videos he just
doesn't have that much time he's he's
going to leave something behind
well guess what got left behind
there was there is one thing that got
left
out there's one thing i got i got behind
on because of the work we were doing
what was it that was the clips channel
oh
yes it hasn't posted in three weeks
still
yeah yeah to this day yes yes i'm
catching i i'm catching up right now so
it was a few other things also like like
like just generally speaking if i was
like hey alex do you want to shoot
sponsors right now you're like oh i know
i got a stuff to do like i didn't get
like last night like i'd be like i'd be
like we can't do it till 8 p.m yeah yeah
like alex was a lot stricter with like
his time and i i couldn't utilize him
definitely not nearly to the like
potential that i used to sure you know
get work done with them you know so yes
there was no way and you know what i
said i said guys alex won't be able to
juggle these two things at once it's
just way too much work and graham and
alex
laughed at me they laughed at me and
they're like oh no alex is gonna be able
to do it just fine it's not gonna have
an issue
well it did
and whose end had the issue
this guy all right jack you you were
right you were right the
to justify it
i was looking at how fast graham was
editing at the time and he was editing
within what three to five hours
and now he's like oh like that's easy
just you know like a couple days and
then you get it down and
uh but inevitably we were wrong and you
were right well that's okay you guys
still i still love you guys but first
i'd like to thank our sponsor vinovest
hey alex what are you invested in wine
w-i-n-e is that like in the end no no
man no no wine like drink oh you invest
in a drink yeah man and vino vest is
actually the best and easiest place to
do it investing in wine has actually
been one of the best kept secrets from
the ultra wealthy for many reasons
two of which being maturity and scarcity
maturity means a 12 year old bottle of
wine will be more valuable than a two
year old bottle and there's also a
finite amount of investment grade wine
and once that vintage wine is bottled no
more can be made not only that but it's
also diversification into another asset
class on top of all that performance of
wines can actually be quite stable in
fact there are multiple wine indexes
that have outperformed the global
equities market over the past 30 years
with all that said i think it's pretty
safe to say investing in wine can be
quite appetizing really anyways vinovest
has you covered they have a super simple
and clean interface that shows you
exactly how your investments are
performing over time i've been toying
around with their app recently and i
really love it so go get started
diversifying your portfolio today with
vinovest with the link down below in the
description once again guys that's
vinovest link down below in the
description to get started investing in
a new asset class and with that said
back to the podcast so guys yeah enough
about business okay
what's uh what's going on uh personally
here
well
i went on a date two nights ago with a
girl you did not mm-hmm and then the
next morning yeah she's real she's like
a real girl oh yeah okay yeah and then
the next morning i texted her i was like
hey i had a great time last night you
know if you ever want to come over for a
barbecue again uh like maybe sometime
this week
and you know what she said
what nothing
no are you serious
are you kidding me no
what
jack you got to figure out where you're
going wrong dude i don't know man that's
odd i don't know what happened hold on
let's break this down what happened that
night okay so she came over yeah this is
the barbecue one right yeah she was
really quiet immediately as she came
over so my housemate apple was also
bringing a girl over uh a second date
with a girl so they were a little more
familiar and this girl came over for a
first date with me she walked through
the door already she was very quiet okay
i'm gonna have to do like a lot of the
leg work was this your first time
meeting her yes
that's a big ass you can't you can't
bring her into the frat house on the
first date man not a frat house but okay
but you can't bring her into the uh the
frat house
on a first date she doesn't know you and
already you're setting it up no i've
said a double date is not a first date a
double date is something that you do the
third to fifth date the first time
should have just been you and her so you
could get to know her she doesn't need
to know how you interact with other
people uh you could because it's it
that's not a representation of a first
date to be in a group like that so that
that's strike number one when you told
me on a date i thought it was like oh
you already met her and you know now
she's just coming over
bad choice
because think about it this way right
she was really shy really really quiet
yeah how is she supposed to share like
private things with you or things about
herself when she's in front of your
roommate who looks like ninja from
fortnite
yeah well by the way i love how you like
apple no offense no no yeah he's a good
looking guy yeah i wouldn't blame her
for this yeah
but she wasn't she didn't even meet them
for for a little bit like she walked
through the door and we were kind of
speaking but she was quiet at first okay
so i would be too and by the way you
said strike one as though there's
there's going to be more stuff we're
gonna find them but that's your strike
one okay we're gonna we're gonna
identify where it went wrong okay so i
walked in and i introduced her to apple
and i tried to introduce her to apple's
girl that he had over
didn't remember her name so you didn't
no
that's okay okay cool all right so
that's not strike two no and then
basically i just gave her her tour of
the house i showed her around and then
we went and played ping pong
and no you showed her the ping pong room
yeah i showed her the entire house you
and her plate yeah just her and i yeah
so we were just like this was like our
first time really just like talking did
you mention that she was into ping pong
uh she said she's never played before
she was terrible man
i mean yeah and knowing you you're very
competitive yeah so i immediately just
you didn't obliterated her you didn't go
no of course i went easy on her yeah but
anyways we kind of like flirted and
talked about like our hobbies and
passions stuff like while we're playing
ping pong and then uh we started cooking
up burgers and then we ate some burgers
we kind of hung out we then went in the
hot tub with apple and his date
jack
and then uh your hot tub's tiny too no
it was sizable and then apple's date
went home apple went upstairs and then
she stayed with me for about an hour and
we kind of hung out on the couch and
just chatted
and then she left and didn't get back to
me over text which is you know totally
peachy maybe she'll get back to me in
like the next week or so
i think one thing i wanted to bring up
was graham finally went on his first
vacation in five years five like a real
vacation like this was like a few days
he's been like on couple day vacations
and stuff real vacation and i actually
went to ventura which if you guys didn't
know is meet kevin's hometown and i hung
out with kevin basically every single
day i was in ventura which was probably
four or five days and we went for runs
and did stuff together
and i was talking with kevin we were
wondering how this vacation is going to
change you and i said that there are one
of two outcomes one you realize that you
enjoy taking time off and you want to
try to find other ways where you'll
you'll be able to work and get ahead and
and kind of like optimize your work to
be able to take these little vacations
here and there because you enjoy the
stress-free life of vacationing
or two the realistic answer two exactly
would be that you had a nice time but
you were stressed and you kind of wanted
to get back to work and now since you're
back at work you feel more comfortable
and you're excited to attack the next
work day and you're very content
definitely definitely number two i mean
there were parts of the vacation where i
just wanted to wake up early and just
work and uh but i like that like i like
the feeling of if i could start which
hawaii time i could start at like four
o'clock in the morning work until 11 or
12 and then i'm done and i feel good i
feel energetic like that's what gets me
energized is working
um my favorite part was definitely scuba
diving there's nothing else like it i
loved that uh and we went to a few nice
dinners there so it was cool
uh but yeah day three day four i was
just like i don't know i i felt like i i
couldn't just
do i don't want to say do nothing
because we did stuff all day long but i
liked in a perfect world i would have
just woken up early worked for six hours
and just had the rest of the day
so i'm more of a fan of the the weekend
trips like i i would love to leave a
friday night come back sunday yeah
because i mean we really grinded to get
ahead uh because i was helping graham
edit at the time and i think um for a
few days before that we were on it
but i remember what you told me before
you left you said
it just feels so wasteful
to get ahead
and then
post those videos on schedule and then
not be ahead anymore i know
we because we got a week ahead which
which i had not been a week ahead in
probably a year maybe no probably two
years for a full week on all three
channels and then to get back and be
like all right
uh back to square one again you couldn't
even enjoy the vacation no i enjoyed it
i enjoyed it but there was certainly a
part of me where uh i was like oh i
could get ahead even more
so graham yeah
one thing that's happened was i started
up my channel mm-hmm and alex is
starting up his channel yeah i want to
get your taste first of all i already
had my channel sorry uh bringing it back
to life yeah you're gonna start posting
again uh i wanna know your opinion on
our channels and you watched one of my
videos you reacted to it on the graham
stefan show you never really said what
you thought about the video as a whole
it's good video it's a really good video
the skits were hilarious you liked the
skits i did yeah they were good thank
you they were
honestly they're like that little jedi
when you're watching the video it's like
that little gem that really and i've
learned to implement that in graham's
videos and i think you did a great job
of it without even realizing
my only complaint was that it wasn't
eight minutes i know but but i didn't
want to make it eight minutes but your
video was really good thank you yeah you
probably i mean the only thing is you
probably would have been able to achieve
85 to 90 of the same thing
with
just 20 of that effort like you could
have just held my phone and walked
through the house i didn't want 89 of
the effort i've just spent so much time
on video i bet the video would be at 30
000 views regardless of you could have
just posted a normal tour and saved that
time to post three more videos
i'm so i am so confident that i am not
gonna adhere to some sort of posting
schedule like i'm just gonna post when
i'm ready and when the final video is
like done and it's quality 10 out of 10
quality
no posting schedule for me okay so
graham yeah
are you afraid
that jack's channel might take off
you wouldn't leave the podcast
i didn't see the podcast yes
but some of the other stuff
no jack will find a way around it
i'm not worried what do you think jack
yeah that's true even if my channel like
takes off depending on what i'm doing
it's like what if my channel takes off
and all of a sudden people want to see
me travel somewhere
then there's going to be an issue but i
will say most likely
that's not going to happen and i'm still
going to continue living in vegas like
like and i would not end the podcast
like that's
my favorite that'd be a bad decision in
general i think i agree yeah yeah what
about the opposite what about me
what if i do well
i i need to have uh one of some of the
no compete contracts yeah you really do
you gotta you gotta have some sort of
rake from his uh from his profits no i
wouldn't take away what about you like
what team 10 a rake from a prom no
because then it just seems petty yeah uh
unless graham's collecting like three
hundred dollars from us
no it's like i i would say cuz like i'm
never gonna ask graham like hey share my
channel i'm never gonna be like hey
shout me out like
that's just not me that's probably not
you it's like oh
no i'm just kidding
subscribe to jack selby subscribe just
look up jack selby i'm like the first
thing that comes up guys subscribe
uh
but no people have been uh wanting to
know that because i i i was reading the
comments and stuff and people were
yeah
my thing is i'm always fine with it as
long as it doesn't interfere with
anything else i think there is a chance
the channel blows up let's just say but
even then you you run the risk of i've
seen so many channels blow up like that
for a few months and then they're dead
after like six to eight months and they
die so you would have to not only blow
up but also sustain that for probably a
year a year and a half to really
solidify yourself so it's it's possible
but i think at the end of the day you
wouldn't
leave the podcast everything else you'd
find a way around it and uh for you for
you alex it would be tougher because
it's harder to outsource that editing
but uh i mean it's just i i know how
much work it takes to to
post because like i don't know it would
have to be like a full-time thing yeah i
i don't want it to be a full-time thing
for me i want it to be
it's really fun but what i did consider
is if it did go well i considered
outsourcing my editing yeah
because
at that point it wouldn't be as much of
a priority as the main channel is um and
then it's like you know if i can find
somebody
that's mine first we have to thank our
sponsor truebill are you tired of paying
subscriptions for services you barely
use are you still getting charged for
that tinder platinum you definitely
didn't sign up for if you answered yes
to any of those questions our sponsor
today truebill is definitely a service
that you're looking for truebill is an
all-in-one personal finance app that
helps you take back control of your
finances from a single dashboard you can
easily cancel unwanted subscriptions set
budgets and lower those bills alex how
much do you pay in bills honestly man
way too much well trouble can actually
help you renegotiate your bills from
services ranging from internet service
provider all the way to credit cards hey
alex what's your credit score i don't
know if i feel comfortable with true
bill you can monitor your credit score
and you'll have complete access to
credit reports and credit history
turbulent also allows me to set budgets
to see how much i earn and also how much
i spend trouble also provides you with a
spending breakdown and it will show you
which categories you need to cut down on
so go ahead and download trueblow with
the link down below in the description
to take control of your finances today
again the link is down below in the
description thank you guys for watching
and back to the podcast my next video uh
right now i'm researching the the worst
hotels
and i'm gonna go spend the night with
kelsey i love it
i wanted to do it for
my honeymoon
that's a that's a good idea yeah i like
it yeah so like we spent our honeymoon
in the worst hotel yes so we're getting
we're having the wedding for those of
you guys that don't know kelsey's my
fiance we're getting married soon we're
getting married in two uh no
through days two days uh but we're not
having the wedding until next year
um
and so yeah i i thought if i had some
free time
that's a great idea yeah i like it a lot
stay a sunday
just enjoy just the whole thing the
whole process in terms of finding the
hotel calling them up booking showing up
i want to see if they have a honeymoon
suite
that would be fun or i want to see like
like can i pay them extra to like get
some chocolates or roses on the bed yeah
yeah i want to see if they could do that
i like the video idea a lot but you came
out with a banger thumbnail and
obviously refined that title a little
bit yeah
that could do really well i agree guys i
appreciate it especially if it's filmed
well yeah we i haven't seen that style
where you set up the camera and then you
like get away yeah yeah yeah yeah but
you come up here
and then take a black light like dude
remember that one remember that yeah
yeah
they would they would inspect hotel
rooms and they'd get there with the you
know black lights and they'd look
through the bed do you guys do that
kelsey doesn't know about this do you
think i should like
not tell her
yeah don't tell her it's better
she'd be like yeah like she'd be like
okay so she'd also be shocked just say
we're going to be studying at a hotel we
got a really good deal
it's just going to be great and then get
her reaction and say you're going to be
filming it so you could use it as a
write-off yeah i would be vlogging it
like i just thought this would be a
great night and and it'd be cool to like
obviously depending on how the night
goes but um maybe bring some like
activities that we could do and just at
the end of the i wanted to have a
wholesome ending at the end but i don't
want it to be about our relationship i
wanted to be about the hotel okay yeah
[Music]
so guys we have a very special
announcement we actually have another
guest coming on
you won't believe who it is all right
come on in
so welcome our new guest thanks for
coming on yeah hi thank you for having
me you just appeared alex was just there
what happened yeah i don't know i mean
even the seat reset and everything macy
we're so excited to have you here you're
actually doing something very
fascinating this month
vlogmas
yeah it has been
yeah i would imagine i don't know how
else to wear that uh yeah so essentially
i'm taking on the job of three people as
one person and graham knows i just have
not had any time
she's been posting for vlogmas basically
means you post one video every single
day for the entire month of december
yeah uh and even like with the way i
edit and the way i do my videos i spent
the whole time alex was in here and
before i left earlier just trying to
find a few videos that i liked for a fun
little intro
to pull tiny quotes of people talking
about bitcoin
oh that's right guess what this is this
is big
macy
bought her first bitcoin
no you didn't yes for reference because
i do get asked this a lot i only own 100
dogecoin and now 300 of bitcoin i don't
put anything into cryptocurrency i'm not
willing to just let burn so probably
won't be investing a lot more into it i
honestly like it's just something i
don't 100 believe in
and i know
stocks so much better than crypto so i
don't it's not like it feels a little
bit more like a gamble to me because i
don't know what i'm doing yeah
so someone's knocking at the door you
want to let him in yeah
it's jack's girlfriend so we also have
another guest coming on the podcast yeah
here we go welcome bailey
what's your qualm with cryptocurrency
all right
we got to know the drama what happened
between you and crypto well nothing's
really happened my whole issue is that
it's just harder for me to research and
i'm not as well versed in it like i've
always i've had a
very keen understanding of stocks i
think especially for
um like you know i don't know a lot of
other girls in high school that were
interested in mutual funds and etfs and
stuff like that and so
things like that i've always understood
and had an easier time understanding
because like companies okay i can
understand what you're doing a little
bit better i can understand what your
product is
understanding like because i've worked
hr roles and different stuff and i've
seen how people get paid kind of looking
okay you have this many employees this
is your administrative costs makes sense
and stuff i don't have that for
cryptocurrency and i don't have like i
just i'm so uneducated that's more my
my qualm
uh i called bitcoin a stablecoin and
people had to correct me
when did that happen uh in a vlog a few
days ago i said i think it's what's
called a stable cane i don't know it's
just like an og and yeah
that's exactly why i'm not in crypto but
it's because i know i don't understand
but you could research it though
i think many times better spend on
stocks i've made so much more off of
stocks than i would well even with how
much i have in in like my
cryptocurrencies if it does not
do what it does with end phase i'm like
well why wouldn't i just find another
end phase
like my original end phase investment
was like 500 and i'm like up like a few
hundred percent on that now well
ethereum's up like fifteen hundred
percent though over i think it's over
the last two years
fifteen hundred percent yeah but you're
also kind of a crypto skeptic as well
like you have extremely small portfolio
allocation to it it's like six percent
yeah that's like not that much like when
you when you look at other people like
like andre
and even kevin i think has i don't know
how much no in terms of he trades in
terms of dollar amount kevin has more
than me but i have almost as much as
andre i just don't understand it that's
my whole thing it's like i don't
understand it so it's not smart for me
to be investing in this it's just like
if you had somebody who their whole life
they only invested in real estate you
try to say hey you should invest in
stocks it's just a whole other world
that i have a harder time wrapping my
brain around yeah i agree with the
sentiment that if you find something
that you're good at investing in you
should just continue investing in that
and kind of find your sp like
specialization kind of like what granted
with real estate
so i agree with that but you know what
mesa you like you like dogs right
oh my god well there is a cryptocurrency
for dogs oh my god i know i i i to
support the dogecoin millionaire because
i think he's a great person i bought a
hundred dollars of dogecoin it is a
challenge like i definitely don't think
i know enough about cryptocurrencies but
i still invest a pretty significant
amount of my portfolio into into crypto
like i'm probably at like 12 to 14 right
now that's why it dropped and i'm going
to continue buying it speaking of which
did you sell robin hood i have not sell
driving can you do it no no i don't want
to say well first of all it's not during
market hours for those that don't know
we're recording this at like i don't
even know what time it is like so it
sells in the morning
but just places sell and then dude i'm
so bullish on robin hood that's the
issue man
we were at the gym i don't know how long
this was like four weeks ago five weeks
ago
and
i i kind of looked over at graham's
phone as you do and i noticed he was
purchasing a stock and usually when
grant purchases a stock i'm like ooh how
can i lose both he and i a little bit
more money today
so i looked at the stock and it was
robin hood and then i went immediately
on my phone didn't mention anything and
graham then did the exact same thing to
me that i just did to graham and he
peeked over at my phone and saw that i
was replicating his trade and
immediately he was like no no no don't
do that don't do it because
every time i buy a stock guys it drops
it drops you want to know the worst part
of this that you probably aren't aware
of
he sees me trade that stock then he goes
and does that and then you see him do it
so you're awesome it's a chain reaction
i've noticed when macy brings up his
stock to me i'll buy it secretly and it
does go up adobe was one of those stocks
uh and i just bought it i honestly i
didn't do any research i was like yeah
you know what i may as well that's
stressful no because it's it's a small
enough amount where i don't care if it
drops it's not going to drop 50 i was
like the worst case is it drops 20 i
don't care
uh so but they've all done well uh ajivo
oh gosh you mentioned gevo when it was
like four dollars
and that it that it went heavy in gevo
and then it went to like 15.
in my opinion chivas overvalued
i don't know a little bit like i
especially like when you're shooting up
to 20 i was like
yeah what is going on here this is just
shooting up because like the the founder
yes was listed as the head of side
science for biden yes
okay but this has nothing to do with the
company it's credibility but now jack on
the other hand buys it
so i immediately plan it jack just don't
buy it like the one stock please don't
buy it he's like i'm gonna buy it and
then sure enough it tanks the next day
52 week low like literally literally 52
week low they miss earnings uh they get
hacked
and they're they're the lowest level
they've ever been yeah i bought probably
like a month ago and i'm already down
like nearly 40 percent
really bad and i bought in really heavy
too as an explorer jack please just sell
it and we'll just see how it does you
could buy back in after 30 days but take
the loss now
write it off
and just do me that favor how much do
you have invested in robinhood
how much did i invest
how much how much uh did you invest in
robin hood 220 grand and what's it at
now
140 150.
yeah so that's why that's why i get
upset because when jack does it it's
like a hundred
no it was a significant amount of money
no i invested
i want to say it was close to 10 grand
that i invested in and that's like worth
me losing
like seven eight times that so you could
invest your time well i didn't think
you'd lose that i still believe as a
company there's nothing wrong with it
but the the only thing wrong is the
jacket's in and they drop yeah it's kind
of alleged that they um that they
purposely had influencers pump it up
right before well it's not alleged they
but they know that but every company
does it like like tattooed chef did a
huge marketing push right it's just
there's nothing
robin hood's it's a good app it's the og
and all that but it's been problematic i
love robin hood it's like the best ui of
any brokerage
options is also nice like it it just can
get new users so easily and you can't
see td doing stuff like that you know or
schwab right but there's there's pretty
good competitors out there who haven't
been hacked
five times now yeah but even for me i
don't even care i don't even care about
this one it's like robin hood gets
hacked whatever it's like my account's
fine right and i love the way it looks
it's just so pretty you swipe up to
trade but the stock price cares because
you bought it yeah so i just want to see
if you sell
how does that impact the price the next
day it's going up
it's going up then let me make my money
back but what about me okay you're
saying i just gotta lock in this loss on
robin hood
jack can we circle back to that you like
robin hood as an app i love robert and
you swipe up yeah and it looks like it
looks pretty good
i feel like you're treating it as like a
dating app
you swipe yeah i love swiping it's great
yeah i mean robin hood isn't my favorite
brokerage
or platform i suppose like i like m1 m1
is kind of cool too it's fine but please
sell
you told me you're going to sell adele
is your favorite
yeah anytime i've had to call them too
they're like
do you need to change your address today
is there anything we can help you with
is there anything i can do with you i'm
like and you're on the phone with them
within five minutes i'm like this is
great
like as i'm making my morning tea by the
time it's done like i'm already on the
phone with somebody
um
their app sucks
yeah i'm testing out like this super
sketchy platform right now called trade
zero
hey you know trade zero
trade zero
so we had this guy stephen ducks on the
podcast we still haven't posted it yet
we're probably going to post it sometime
soon and uh he's like a short-term like
day trader and uh basically he said jack
if you put 30 000 into this platform i
can guarantee you basically i can turn
that to 200 000 in a few months how's
that going well i've made one trade so
far
oh
bailey did not like the trade yeah well
i he basically he promised me he could
basically turn thirty thousand to two
hundred thousand and i was like
obviously very wide-eyed at this i was
like yeah get me in on this somehow and
he said he would give me the thirty
thousand dollars to start off with and i
was like i i felt too like wrong taking
his money because i also want it to be
kind of true it's like if i do all of
the trades i put it in all the data
myself you know all the buys all the
cells and stuff like that then it will
feel more real if i turn 30 000 to 200
000. so anyways uh he gave us one signal
i was on do not disturb so i missed the
scene oh come on and uh yeah and my
housemate apple went in on the trade and
he made
i think he made like 600
from like 2 grand so it was a really
really good trade and he made it in 15
minutes and then the next trade this was
i think last last week or two weeks ago
i went in with 5 000
and i made 1700
on the trade not bad okay extremely good
so he's two for two on the trades right
now trade zero the brokerage looks
terrible it looks really bad but i'm
making money so far on it and it's
pretty exciting i did not think that
this the trade steven would give me
would be successful two out of two times
but once again i don't endorse day
trading at all i'm just reporting it how
it is
i'm noticing you guys are finding bailey
very distracting i'm so used to doing
this while filming if i'm talking and
just petting her that way she stays
relatively still but it's really
distracting for you guys no i don't
think it's that distracting in fact i
think it's kind of nice the viewers will
probably appreciate bailey the viewers
are going to love it yeah so macy i
already spoke to graham about this but
what was your opinion on the hawaii
vacation oh my gosh i could have stayed
there for like a month
i loved it
and what was your favorite thing you
didn't know why uh probably the scuba i
think part of me liked the snoop because
i didn't like have all the stuff snort
like strapped onto me but um i did run
into a sea urchin or i got stabbed
actually um if you saw my video i got
stabbed by a sea urchin and i do have
the footage of that as well because i
strapped a gopro onto myself
um but
yeah i i think the scuba was just
awesome i liked swimming around with
things um
it was a lot of fun saw like turtles
like a foot for my head that i didn't
know where the hair would just turn over
me like oh gosh they don't care that's
cool yeah so you want a vacation again
sometime soon oh i would love to
what what do you think about that i get
with the point that graham and i are in
our lives that it's hard even i want to
go back and see my family right now but
i can't it's hard for me um
it's just you know kind of the kind of
the trade-off is you work hard
young in your life and
you know then you can start taking those
vacations later on and that's kind of
what we both talked about i would say if
you visit your family though that's
content because then it's like traveling
then it's seeing your family you get the
whole interaction with you and your
family and you get to see him at the
same time so i would i would encourage
that yeah i think that would actually
keep your vlog a little dynamic you know
yeah yeah no i i mean i get that i'm
also doing that workout challenge right
now it's so hard for me to travel
yes 60 gnarly workouts 60 days in a row
right yeah 60 days
well absolutely funny enough so what we
found out uh
going through it with my personal
trainer and um dietitian well you get a
personal trainer with this but it was
like someone i usually attended their
workout classes um
i over work out and i don't eat enough
so it's this challenge has been work out
less
and eat more and that's been the real
challenge for me because i stopped
working out so heavy so my stomach
shrunk
and so now when i'm trying to eat foods
like i eat a banana and i'm stuffed for
hours
and i need to be eating more
yeah
yeah do they want you to put on muscle
like it seems like okay then that's yeah
so that was my goal is i wanted to build
muscle okay
huh
chiseled by the end
but you would think to be well i guess
you build muscle and then you restrict
carbs so you do the cut
so then you could lose
that to get it
you need carbs like it's very bulk up
right uh for me it's more just about
wanting to be able to move my body a
little bit less than like
looks i mean i you know it is nice to
feel like i look good but um
scary we gotta zoom in on your face
right there jeffy it was horrifying no
it's just more for me about feeling that
strength there's something super cool to
me too about like
you know i lost my ability to walk yeah
if you keep working out that much you're
gonna be stronger than graham
oh let's not get ahead of it we did an
arm wrestle and uh i was the the
champion you know what graham
i also was the victor arm wrestling macy
it would be kind of interesting to see
who would be the victor between
you and i um
yeah what i will say is that i could i
could beat you in like a planking
challenge super oh yeah
there are certain ways i'm already
stronger than you but um arms no what do
you think you just always maintain arm
muscle mass like if i stop working out
my arms just go
noodle
yeah might just keep getting bigger if i
don't work him out makes no sense no it
doesn't who would who would win uh arm
wrestling who would win i i have a
my thinking is that you would win jack
because your arms are longer than mine
so i think you would have more leverage
on my on my arm i think graham's going
to win i think it's going to be tough
but um i graham just immediately flopped
me over and you and i had two seconds
before you pushed me over do you think
it's going to be pretty do you want to
judge
[Music]
i was closer with jack wow
you're strong but you know what but yeah
that's that's uh i had a feeling you
would you'd win you have a longer uh
i may have had a more advantageous
position since i could like kind of i
wouldn't have to lean so far back off
the table i don't know
that's probably it
anyways gang
thank you so much for coming on macy
thanks graeme for making this happen
with me it's our first midweek episode
ever uh yeah
so uh thanks for tuning in guys we're
gonna do oh let us know what you think
of these if you like them we're gonna do
more of them so all you have to do if
you want to see more comment down below
subscribe hit the like button most of
the way can you guys explain what a
midweek episode would be if you guys
continue yeah if we were to do a midweek
episode it would it'd probably be a
small group
potentially just a family and then also
potentially a guest if we have a guest
on it and we just have because a lot of
the times now it's a lot easier to book
guests and i would love to ramp up
production of this uh of the podcast and
just continually post maybe five times a
month then six times a month and just uh
start adding more mid weeks yes would
you put people on that like maybe the
channels seen before like jeremy yeah
yeah we're gonna continue earth yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna continue doing
people like that from midweeks but
big gas like new people and stuff
ideally that would be reserved for the
sunday but i'm really happy to start
filming more podcasts and people have
been asking for it for a while so
yeah yeah i think recurring guests could
be more so midweek yeah uh jeremy kevin
andre yeah midweek absolutely yeah
all right guys thanks so much for tuning
in have a great day oh subscribe oh
subscribe and get your free stock down
below in the description subscribe to my
youtube channel link down below it's the
first link no it's not it's gonna be
like the six link but uh
savannahsmilesyt on instagram
savannasmiles on youtube thank you guys
so much for watching use the amazon
affiliate link in her description
until next time bye